loin de s'excuser avant de commencer
cette vidéo je voulais vous remercier
mon petit cachottier parce que ça se
fête mon anniversaire comme ça sur
twitter
et ça fait passer le hashtag en
entendant ce méfait moi j'ai rien
n'était nous pour faire des
remerciements mais merci j'ai
l'intention est super mignonne ce super
mignon et puis écoutez je vous souhaite
un joyeux anniversaire à tous en avance
ça porte malheur le malheur à vous
suivre maintenant c'est gratuit petite
malédiction dans tes yeux alors
aujourd'hui on se roule sur gée possible
quiz 2 parce que oui pour un
anniversaire finalement on va se
torturer la gueule
go go go c'est parti souvenez vous c'est
ses quizz complètement abusé première
question où le général gare de ses
armées dans des casernes dans un bac à
madagascar ou aux pistes livide je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire on va la jouer
logique dans des casernes bah voilà
c'est pas ça c'est évident le truc qu'on
sait pas olalala c'est fantastique de
voir
j'avais oublié la joie que tu attends tu
es à moi une question duquel des
ingrédients suivants tu as besoin pour
construire une maison verte des briques
de la peinture de la vodka ou des vitres
ses briques ou peinture je pense à mon
avis briques voilà [ __ ] peinture voilà
parce que vers la maison verte vous
voilà lequel est le plus grand la terre
mars la galaxie ou milky way à mars le
but non voilà je pense qu'il a fait la
blague le mars à friandises mais non
puis oui j'ai tenté la fente
ok c'était la terre qu'est ce que c'est
que ça c'est une conserve qui rigole une
boîte boîte une boîte heureuse l'âme de
noël ou un américain
ça c'est une réponse finale je pense pas
qu'ils ont avec soi mignon devrait
plutôt dire un américain all à l'appui
sur ces tu crois pas une seconde à 6 ok
carottes d'accord parfait coup
médiatique de l'aide dans cette phrase 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
je te bats que bell c'est faux 6,6 et
game over le tout premier à l'est on
recommence 29 du coup 8 utilise la bonne
clé à c'était piège de la couleur a été
la même couleur la bleue ok ok
donc c'est aucune des cas parfait rien à
déplacer à
là je bloque un là je sache les cours
comme toi excellent on s'amuse
key ses touches aussi appuyé sur la
touche de droite touche de droite
oh là là c'était après les droits sur le
clavier
cros le courroux la grande muraille de
chine commence au bar de la chine
justice iliad il est dedans
j'aime bien celle là a alors évolué qui
s'il faut faire what what what what faut
cliquer comme un gros porc whaou
qu'est ce qui se passe si tu ramasses en
pingouin déjà je peux cliquer là ah non
à la voilà mais ta souris ici ok or ça
c'est super chiant ça vraiment j'ai
envie de tout casser on est déjà la
douzième alors répond à cette question
la tête à l'envers en compte uc réponse
doit le dire ok super ok sauf concombre
tient plus longtemps à réfléchir plus
j'ai des chances de m'évanouir
ok tamer fine non gerber au cas où ma
réaction
j'ai envie de chialer but à hawaï five
avec canaux les allemands arrosent leurs
jardins de la pluie de leur hymne des
oreilles watts lederhosen c'est une
culotte allemande voilà qui ressemble à
ça ça me paraît trop grossier pour être
ça donc gérer avec de la pluie ces fonds
lederhosen bah voilà [ __ ] faut
compléter sa est-ce que c'est super
chiant d'accord sa forme la question ok
a marqué it's the quest ix number un
truc comme ça qui est dieu le père de
jésus le créateur de l'univers l'arrière
train d'un chien ou un mec assez gros
avec une superbe barbe le créateur de
l'univers l'arrière-train des chiens
quel est le nom du chat dans une
poubelle couiza et j'en sais rien mais
glen
or comme il s'appelle ce [ __ ] de la
crise ok parfait blanc ou marron [ __ ]
mais c'est quoi ça ah d'accord
voilà en fait vous que le ballon arrive
sur ta souris et la nourriture préférée
de spider man
les sandwichs volant non c'est trop
facile oh la la la la la facilité qu'est
ce que c'est que ça alors ça mon gars
une bombe un [ __ ] violet et fut
stoppeur jeu parce que c' est l' un de
ces trucs là là un [ __ ] mauvais nom à
l'un de ces trucs là boîte à droite
comme à donges arrête ça ok journée
baiser à dieu je vous aime et tous ok
pour les frêles faire péter les boutons
du matin au caire où explosent oh là là
là là on sent le mec a fait ça tout seul
adolescent comme une question le tout
premier poste siebel quiz avait c'est
trente ans je crois qu'elle du tueur
hors norme [ __ ] de quoi la barbe à
papa est elle constituée de nuages roses
de coton de sucre ou de fleuves fleuve
c'est du duvet de barbe à au nom coton
non à cissé nuage rose violet mauvais on
s'en fout alors comment on fait pour
gagner
bah je suis la croix oléron ça la
question comment jeu comment tu fais
wind peut-être la touche windows non à
phalaborwa le rôle c'est pas mal là je
m'abonne et je suis sur google puisque
aucun de ces éléments peuvent être
trouvées dans la mer les crabes l'espace
les tétons ou la chine
les tétons
adieu les sites où vous s'aimer pts de
l'espace quand est ce qu'une porte n'est
pas une porte quand c'est un cochon
quand c'est un poke ans et d'un bouton
alors la mecque mais je dirais quand
même quand c'est un cochon a les bonnes
réponses
aux tchèques à pau à un troupeau de moi
tu t'approches que fais-tu gelé dégage à
travers une fenêtre je cours je leur
patte dessus où je frappe dans leur
jolie rhin gérer leurs pets dessus eh
ben c'est faux je cours au ticket au cou
et press one jaune rouge vert honorait
swan peut-être celle de la question
reste one one one
c'est au coeur des boutons mais j'en ai
marre après soit en tête de chiffres un
conte la bombe et n'est plus qu'à une
seconde d'exploser attention ma théorie
ce que ce ça j'ai envie de chialer eux
c'était l'un du clavier c'est ça merci à
tous parce que ça m'a vraiment fait
plaisir merci à tous ça c'est pour moi
monsieur
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça this is
partance au oui bah voilà c'était très
instinctif et ensuite et ensuite vous
faire quoi
quoi c'est quoi ça non mais alors [ __ ]
je vais pas temps de réagir combien du
trou d'air dans un rôle aux 1 2 3 4
c'est un piège c'est un piège c'est un
piège simple zéro olalalala c'est être
exact et de le numéro de la question
j'avais parlé comment tu mets de
baleines dans une voiture une devant une
derrière tu le fais pas tu es idiot
gradins de m4e tu le fais pas alors tu
es idiot c'est pas jamais insulté
créateur du jeu rise of the night vois
je sais pas si c'est le pic noz quoi
nous nous donnons aux noces [ __ ] j'ai
paniqué qu'est-ce que j'ai appuyé sur
tout sauf sur ce bateau là la réponse
ressemble à une paire de cul nu britney
spears norway bonne note
dirty boy c'est une blague c'est aucun
des quatre alors ça j'aime pas ça c'est
de l'arnaqué
d'accord ce président qui lui before the
bond aux banon il a menti
le conte comment du jour fléchettes avec
un bébé tu fais très attention tu le
fais pas tu vises la tête où tu portes
un dossard
as tu partes à dos a alors tu vises la
tête
voilà bah évident pourquoi le mexicain
jette sa femme d'une falaise pour une
chose semble l eau tequila farid sont
ils adorent les fajitas
voilà revoir bonne chose sam laidlaw
tequila tu as besoin d'un éléphant
d'accord il faut sortir sa souris du jeu
et ça fait tomber un éléphant en fait
parfait mach machault metter
oh la la
ouattara mais mon bien maintenant le mec
tu assures elle devient visible c'est
beaucoup trop dur ok là c'est la
difficulté on va se concentrer et ça va
passer j'arrive pas à bordel
booth a fait jamais ce que je vais faire
le mec il est un bon gars sauf que je
n'ai pas vu je me spoil
c'est le genre de merde
kelly imposible quiz t'a aidé à voir les
choses cachées tout quand tout allait
tous bretons mat aux toilettes [ __ ]
toucan parfait appuyé sur le plus petit
était pas le point du oui c'est ça non à
phu juste à temps décalé cette question
la question what flower isker dit boy
honey eux wise ici aux questions de marc
n'ont quà attend l'ex abusé ya le même
timer pour quelques questions qui
suivent quoi je me suis même plus que
j'ai me up temps je vais tomber en
dépression il faudra un sas la pompe
dépressurisée
allez on passe l on le passe pitié pitié
pitié pitié j'ai envie de chien je veux
chialait je chiale vraiment c'est là
pour faire fois que je chiale d'avoir
[ __ ] de jeux vidéo
oui bah ouais je regarde cette vidéo sur
ces possibles le quiz denis jouait pas
facile a plus ces cas ne s'était pas
aimé la vidéo que d'habitude et à sécher
mes larmes en me prêtant un petit
bouchon
sheila edge et la m je me dis j'ai joué
deux heures j'aurais aimé aller jusqu'au
bout alors se tourner vers une prochaine
vidéo jeux portez vous bien